hi I'm Justine welcome to my channel you
may know me from YouTube have an idea
I'm at this restaurant I am a passion
for or you may know me from some random
TV appearance she's here waiting for
Jeremy
he's a germy Gilbert yeah inspired last
week either way I'd love for you to
subscribe to my channel I make videos
every Monday Wednesday and Friday here
on YouTube calm I just seen so if you're
subscribed you will get those directly
to you I make all kinds of videos
anything from music videos videos about
Apple and Technology do you know what's
this ha ha he said I've had mini you
would be a hundred percent correct
heaven sometimes dancing in Apple stores
an occasional make up video those live
in the club I'm going to the love
videogames random things that have no
category
seriously the list just goes on and on
I'm like the Bob Ross of Draw Something
why didn't you go I've noticed you like
five times I'm making videos here since
2006 which is a very very long time so
hi to everyone who has been subscriber
since the beginning and hello and
welcome to all of you new subscribers
there's ever a video that you want to
see me make be sure to leave it in the
comments
tweet it to me Facebook it to me
Instagram it some sort of virtual means
of communication and you may see it in a
future i justi video I'll see you guys
in the next video I post
[Music]